you never know when being kind to a
stranger could change your life we've
talked about this time and time again on
this show in a now viral video tick
tocker becca moore says a california
hotel called an uber to take her to a
phone store after a man stole her phone
her keys and her wallet at the coachella
music festival last month well the
driver of that uber his name is raul
torres he stuck with more the entire day
to make sure she was safe he even bought
margaritas
okay and helped her file a police report
after he mentioned his daughter was
diagnosed with cancer two years ago
moore created a fundraising page for
torres's family and get this it has
topped 150 000
oh wow and we spoke with both of them
listen wow
paying it forward even if you think it's
a small thing of like walking in with
someone to a store like that changed my
entire the course of maybe like the next
few weeks of my life because of him
serving my wife sometimes she'll tell me
like
you help out everybody you know and
stuff like that and i'm like eventually
i'll need help one day and somebody will
end up helping me out
and um
i guess that was
this day you know
and um
she's a beautiful person
you never know mr torres yes
and see what he's going through you know
he's going through his daughter has
cancer his father just passed away from
cancer and so you never know talk about
this all the time everybody has a story
everybody on this planet has a story if
you just take time to listen to them
i love that she set up a gofundme page
to help them and doing something kind
without looking for something in no
strings no strings attached yes and then
seeing the world open up itself to you
saying here you go thank you for your
act of kind could not have possibly
anticipated or expected that that would
happen